we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p once again i
can't mention even the guests can't
mention sam harris without me receiving
angry voicemails from people who just
aren't listening to what I'm saying
take a listen to this list sick if you
think that you know he is not even
remotely a white nationalist or at least
becoming a useful idiot for the movement
or anything like that you never provide
any evidence of it you just keep
allowing guests to say that without
challenging come about it why don't you
try having him on your show one day okay
number one we've invited Sam Harris on
the program and he has never declined
but he just doesn't get back to us so
he's welcome to come on to the program
at any time most importantly I have
never said that Sam Harris is a white
nationalist contrary to the dozens of
emails and voicemails that I get I have
never said Sam Harris is not an
intellectual we're actually going to be
talking about this more on the Friday
show during audience questions and with
regard to what our guest said Christian
peach aleni
on today's show about Sam Harris being a
sort of useful idiot for white
nationalism by his entertainment of some
of these race-based race IQ ideas that
was the guests position and I did follow
up about it but ultimately the entire
interview is not going to become about
that so please don't attribute
statements about Sam Harris to me that
I've never made nor even even even
implied it's just I'm just not saying it
right go talk to the people that are
actually saying those things we've got a
great bonus show for you today including
the Catholic Church and the abuse
scandal that's going on we will talk
about strange recommendations regarding
urination to Parisian tourists and also
the world's 10 most livable cities none
of which are in the United States of
America those stories and more on
today's bonus show sign up at WWE at
medCom or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show